hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play condemned
ok we're chasing the guy in the orange
while he's not in the orange anymore but
who my spidey sense tingling wellness
that's it hey don't be like that if
that's it baby
ok it's a map of the tunnels received
you can't figure that out schedule
there's some shadows
Veronica through graphics enhancement
chances rathole alright it has to be
I found his overalls mixed with Locker
elder travels light doesn't he keep
looking around he's gotta have more than
a locker to play with I'll get back to
you once I clean up this image ok kick
out wall fan and climb through okay
alright then
yeah hey get back here hey I styie get
back here
I'm gonna catch up I'm gonna get you
with my hammer
one more good job good job
fire is required okay I'm good this guy
I'm coming for you oh hey there should
have been a fire axe there dig oh hello
okey dokey this seems awfully convenient
but whatevs you shouldn't have given me
an axe
oh come on Thomas speaking document is a
standard city issue dream scared no
kidding baby pressure has been applied
from a stylus highlighting juice
real originating from central metro
station route 16 to Burnside departing
5:10 7:30 9:30 a.m. route 66 B leads to
briar that's a tiny farm town an hour to
the northwest why do I need emergency
why's is his hub so he goes to both
locations regular okay
I've also determined DNA from the sweat
sample of the train matches DNA from the
cigarette bottom cigarette by 99.8%
probably yeah he's a smoker the guy
you're following is the guy who killed
the Tim policeman ah at least I think so
something's still not adding up that's
such a nice name for a murderer he's the
matchmaker huh that's so nice ha ha ha
did doctor you're not even gonna get out
of there I got my goose on the head Oh
oh my I do now I'll I'll just smack you
in half Hey don't run Oh
all the ladies run away from me not fair
I took the dope hey you hey not fair ya
hear what the hell what where'd you go
where'd you go ha hey come back here I'd
really do seem like a crazy murderer now
come on baby where do you come ah sorry
sorry for this oh that was mean I would
never treat a lady like that even though
I hunted her down with my fire axe shot
her with my taser and then picked up
this gun yes
how many shovel - that's it all come on
I know there was a health thingy
here her blue - oh it's already open
never mind just kick me here for no
reason so I just had to get my can can
dance out of the way now I'm good to
kill I'm the weirdest policeman axe
murderer there ever is I know the great
secret of this game I'm really the
murderer I am yeah steam valve I always
made that connection I just never seen
hurt it been that way valve steam steam
valve steam valve valve steam 15 Bell
seam down okay
yep I don't know it's gonna mess with
the murder
I think it's like all in this guy's mind
just like the cry of fear in afraid of
monster you oh hello there hello hello
friend how about a murder
I remember Oh with that oh you want to
live too bad how would you get your boo
I'm unstoppable what was I doing
oh yeah this one
one I got one boom bang II left what is
that where from where oh you got your
damn you know take that how many bullets
four it's okay only three of them went
in my head come on out here enemies
enemies I am ready for you I wasn't
ready for that last guy but I'm ready
for you I'm here poop
den dirt like about wow how did you die
tell me how you dad what the what come
on
what oh I see oh my mother's hey why
don't these guys die anymore nope let me
out him never snap oh
and I am brutal I can't looks like a
frickin vampire from some stupid teenage
heartthrob or film whatever you want to
call those things
up bet big Oh
oh don't tell me there's a dead bird in
here yep there's the bird I probably
missed quite a few actually yeah yeah
yeah okay yeah yeah oh yeah yeah yeah oh
yeah come on out I'm not gonna hurt you
a lot
oh yeah fish yeah there we go Oh gotcha
hey hey how did you yeah Oh God yeah
fishin with a bag of mouths hi
yeah you know what I meant okay now I
get to use that other healthcare that's
bad thing I'll be right up
you guys don't even hurt didn't even
hurt I didn't feel a thing
nothing anything else down there
probably nope wait bird
nope okay that was a waste of time Wow I
love running in circles and finding
nothing that's my favorite thing to do
in the world now I'm gonna continue on
my way and do absolutely nothing while I
climb up this ladder OOP okay I didn't
think I'd get you get me that no deserve
it but what's that oh wow
what I love come on me oh that hurt look
at whoa you're wimpier than I thought
you were what that looks like a shadow
of a person ah I need a health kit again
golly I suppose I should have just you
know hit him instead of toying with him
I already got that one but that's not
what I do cuz I'm stupid
it's up here huh
this will hi okay I'm no one just as
much as that needed it
Hey a bird and a shovel I'll take this
shovel whoa so photometer that's not the
shovel yes please thank you oh I love
having that side of the screen covered
up
let's crowd in my face a bit together
open up open your face
give me your secrets hahaha oh you
tricky bastard tricky I mean lady you
fine lady Oh tricky I was not ready for
that may it's like I get sad but I keep
forgetting this this game is kind of
scary it was supposed to be I don't know
shut up it startled me shut up what do
you want from me it startled me
alright come here
move down here down here I'm ready for
you
good that high mana do have it huh I
don't even know where I'm going I
already have a shovel thank you whoa
what the what is that whoa what the hell
oh must be this train going by above
I thought it was like SCP and something
was gonna spawn whoa whoa hey well it's
you
I can one-shot you with a Taser for some
reason every bedroom you come here come
back here not following you you think I
am stupid
ha ha ha ah shut up ah here we go
yep Burt up oh yeah oh that was aroused
um that's just that was bad that that's
not good increased steam pressure to
rupture pipe clearing by steam valve ha
ha ha I heard you from ways off oh hello
Oh lady stop Babbitt Oh what I'm sorry
baby
Oh what up hi hi look the shoal is
effective I'll tell you that I'll tell
you what this sha traded out for this
shovel what is with the white stuff
no like super super bright and I don't
know why
Oh what's this more steam valve don't
turn
okay it's gonna turn on its own I saw
that down there what is going on where's
this sumo okay it's all off now I am so
confused I don't like how sometimes
there's no sound effect to what's going
on I really would like to clue in and we
go through here give me your pain pills
yes I am black Lewis I feel like I get
distracted pretty often from my actual
goal what huh oh I don't like this is
usually where trains come and smash
through try to kill me
what is that
I see if there's anything at the end of
these tracks I'm gonna say first in case
some train call along and kill me bird
bird no bird really numbered was it
nothing he's a whole lot of nothing it's
just a bunch of nothing can I steal you
around the Sun feel free
Oh what are you hunger too big nothing
anyone gets that joke Internet high-five
yea-ah Oh rats
yeah that's so unsanitary
poor guy I don't really care I probably
killed anyway hey but it hey how about
it alright how are you doing there
you all right oh yeah you keep fighting
Wow what the hell goosh way why didn't I
grab the gun
goodnight I need this please these guys
hurt though the guy go I have two
bullets both with half of your name on
each that way when they meet together in
your brain it'll connect to be one gun
bullet in your head and it'll have your
name on it
crowbar required I thought I heard a
gunshot I might have been mistaken
oh hello oh no he has a shotgun I'll
take that please thank you better oh my
gosh get it one more
uno mas I'll take that then I thought
those guys were gonna be much tougher
but I'm just way too badass to even even
come remotely close to being hurt by
them
I am also just up dead bird huh what
uh-oh oh no don't get in this get out
there laughter I am all out of time
please click the annotations for more
Let's Plays that I don't check out my
reaction compilation thank you all so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next video bye bye yeah